This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
for post-do pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
Hello. Hello everybody. Welcome to Daily
with Doc and Becca. My name is Becca
Dukes and as a certified holistic health
coach and certified naturopathic
practitioner, I am honored to have you
on this journey as you are investing
time into yourself and what you as an
empowered individual can do to help
yourself when it comes to health and
wellness. So today is pharmacist Fridays
and I love this day because we have an
amazing pharmacist who just takes the
scientific stuff makes it easier to
understand and you know he's not just a
pharmacist he's also a nutritional
pharmacist a formulation expert and a
relentless educator who has dedicated
his life to helping you and I and others
around the world. So, as a compounding
pharmacist, a skin health and functional
uh nutrition specialist, pharmacist Ben
is uniquely blessed with this ability to
be able to take complicated things and
make them more understandable. And
today, we're going to be talking about
some of the things that uh affect our
skin and hormones and GLP1 and hey, the
heart. So, let's go ahead and bring
pharmacist Ben on. And folks, if you
>> muted, love,
>> thank you. So, you want to make sure
that if you were invited by somebody
specific that you get back with them
because they cared enough about you,
care enough about them to say, "Hey,
thank you." as this program is a
resource for an amazing community and we
want to make sure that we keep the
integrity of that community going
strong. So, if you were not referred by
somebody and you want more information
and want to get connected with a
certified holistic health coach, I do
have a team standing by at 855949
855-9493377
or you can send questions to
questionswithdoc.com
as this program is being sponsored by
Daily.
Am I unmuted now? Okay, so let's go
ahead and get on with today's show. And
pharmacist Ben Fuches, thank you so much
for joining us again. You know, just
before I forget,
we're gonna be in person next week in
Orlando,
and I'm super excited that you're going
to be there with us.
>> I'm super excited as well. I got the
agenda yesterday from AJ. We're going to
get to meet the Orlando Chamber of
Commerce. I'm so excited. I'm going to
be on a panel, I guess, with a couple of
uh a couple of doctors who are going to
be blown away by what I say. Are they
just ordinary doctors? Do we discover
AJ? Are they MDs?
>> Well, we have we have a mental health
specialist. We have um some other folks
who uh don't quite do what you do, but
you know, are almost aligned and we're
going to bring them all the way over.
>> Will it be contentious? Will it be
contentious?
>> You know what? I think Jerry Springer
will be upset that he's
>> No. No. I don't mind if it's
contentious. I have no problem.
>> I don't think Dr. Gary Sipin, can you
unmute and just fill us in a little bit?
>> I I I don't like talking to preaching to
the choir. You know, that's not fun for
me.
>> I don't think it'll quite be the choir,
but I do think that
>> I want to have legitimate legitimate
back and forth, not not from, you know,
ordinary folks, but from medical
professionals.
>> Senator Sipin, are are all these folks
aligned with what we already think or
they have their own different varied
views, you think?
And Senator Sipin, you can turn your
camera on if you'd like and join us on
screen.
>> At least.
>> Okay.
Can you see me? Yeah, I guess you can.
>> That's a good How you doing? That's a
good question. I think some of they're
into holistic health. Uh but Dr. Bane is
uh is kind of like dealing with the
mental health thing.
So, you know, uh, everybody's not like
Dr. Ben, but of course, they got their
own specialty. I
>> I like to have people I like have people
disagree, so I can I can I can teach
them something. That's what I like. I
don't like to preach in the choir.
>> Well, you're going to have some people
disagree. That's fine. I think you'll be
uh
>> That's what I want.
>> That's what I want. Thank you, G. Doc,
Senator Ciplin, thank you so much.
>> Let me ask you this question right here.
You know, I the way way it's going to
work uh next week, we're going to bring
Commissioner uh Scott on board. Uh he's
going to say a few words briefly. My
wife who uh established a building where
the 90 seniors meet. I mean, she
established that building just for the
seniors can meet every Thursday there.
And one of the reason why I wanted to
have it on Thursday is because they're
there every Thursday until about 1:30 in
addition to the other people that we
invite from the public. So, you're going
to have a captive audience of seniors
who meet there every day. I'm quite sure
they're on medication.
>> Okay.
>> So, uh, Commissioner Commissioner
Scott's going to speak first. My wife's
going to speak second. And then, of
course, we got the, uh, uh, Impact,
Project Impact, which is also a
co-sponsor. She deals with helping um,
uh, at risk kids and and homeless kids,
homeless people get housing. And then,
of course, we'll bring you on.
>> So, you know, I got you from 94 9:15
until about 11:00. And I know from
experience being with you every every
Friday, you always run out of time
answering questions. But I do want you
to explain to the pup to the audience
why people get diseases. That's very
important.
>> I'm
then you can answer questions. Okay.
>> I'm happy to do all that. Absolutely.
>> Some of my people are afraid that that
that'll be too long for you. I I don't
know. But
>> no
15 until 11 o'clock.
>> No, no, no. Not don't worry about that.
That's not going to be a problem. I'm
like you. I'm like a politician. I'm
like a politician. Senator, you I could
fill a buster all day long, man. All All
week long, dude. You're not.
>> But you know, they don't understand.
See, I watch you for years, so I
understand what what people want to ask.
And then what we got the panel at 1
11:00 until 12 and then we have lunch at
12:00 until 1. And for some people, they
think that some people don't want to ask
you a question in public and they want
to meet you privately. So an hour
between 12 and 1 so they can meet you p
privately. Okay.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. We're
>> and then we have Dr. Bane come on at
1:00 and he'll do his mentality thing.
Uh if you want to participate in that,
you can do that, too. So that's that's
the schedule. But it's all about being
foos. Okay.
>> I appreciate that, Senator Zlin. Thank
you so much, Senator. Appreciate it.
Hey, when did you go to the University
of Pittsburgh? When did you graduate?
>> Uh 19 uh 77
to 81. And then I went to law school in
Pittsburgh from 81.
>> So you knew Dan Marino
>> 79 81.
>> You knew Dan Marino.
>> Oh yeah. And Tony Dorset.
>> And Tony Dorset. That's right. All
right.
>> Mean Joe Green.
>> You knew all those guys. All right. So
thank you, Senator Sipin. Good to see
you. We'll see you next week.
>> Same here.
>> All right, buddy. Bye bye.
>> All right. And for those of you who do
not know those names, Pixburg Steelers.
Um, growing up I was a fan.
>> You were?
>> Yeah. Steel.
>> I'm just for whoever's playing. Let's
just play a great game. All right. Well,
I was a Raiders fan, so we hated the
Steelers.
Just let's be clear about that. All
right.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much,
Senator Diplin. We are super excited to
be joining you next week. It sounds like
it's going to be just a day full of
being able to be in the public reaching,
sharing, and uh empowering.
So, I'm I love that, Ben. You know, all
the time that
>> Super excited. Super excited. Yes,
ma'am.
Now, one other question if I could if I
could say, you know, uh my my brother
had prostate cancer and of course I uh
had him hook up with AJ and AJ did
recommend some stuff for him and of
course he he doesn't have prostate
cancer again. So, I did invite him
there. So, I don't know how you you know
I brag about it, you know, but I don't
know what's the protocol with you guys,
>> but he's going to be there and some
other folk that AJ's help is going to be
there, too.
>> That's all. We'll we'll we'll let every
We're going to brag on everybody,
>> including you, including you, Senator.
All right. Praise God. That's exactly
right.
>> Awesome.
>> Thank you. Thank you so much. All right.
>> Fantastic. All right. Okay. So, let's go
ahead and
>> let's get the show on the road. As they
say,
>> we got this this show. We got a lot of
people that have skin issues, weight
issues, um heart issues.
Is it related? Is it connected? Can it
be?
>> What? What do we have? We have the
triangle of disease, right? The root.
Root, not fruit.
>> We do
>> root not fruit. Yeah. I What? So
everybody's clear, I sent AJ an article.
By the way, I just sent you another
article, AJ, for our collection there.
Um, so I sent AJ an article on um GLP-1
receptor agonists and dermatitis. Uh,
eczema. Dermatitis and eczema are
synonymous.
And that's really important to
understand because eczema is sort of a
vague word but dermatitis is a specific
word dermis skin titis inflammation. So
dermatitis eczema synonymous is an
inflammation of the skin. What is
inflammation? It's a defensive response.
What's a defensive response? Uh it's a
response to an offending agent. Whenever
you have a dermatitis, you got an
offending agent. That offending agent
could be something like um toxicity that
comes in through foods and activates the
immune system or that toxicity can be
secondary to
destabilization
of the immune system. In other words,
you might just be eating something that
wouldn't affect you. But if your immune
system is destabilized, now it affects
you. So what are the main the main ways?
There's only two that the system becomes
destabilized. Foods and sugar. bottom
point of the triangle of disease. And
this is why you're going to see and
you're starting to see now, but you're
gonna continue to see more and more
studies that talk about how GLP1s help
various health challenges. Couple months
ago, GLP1s were associated with
improvements in dementia. Uh, this one
shows that uh GLP1s are associated with
improvements in dermatitises. Is this
because GLP1s are some miracle drug? No,
it's because GLP1
drugs
improve the body's glycemic response.
They're not some miracle. They want you
to think it's a miracle. It's not a
miracle. It's working at the second
point of the triangle of disease with
sugars. Now, it's a miracle if you don't
want to lay off a sugar. I had a call I
did a a radio show a couple weeks ago on
GLP1s and a guy called up and he said,
"I love my GLP1s. but I lost so much
weight and my blood sugar is better,
blah blah blah. And that's true because
this is I happen to know this guy. He
couldn't get his blood sugar under
control. He couldn't get his weight
under control. He couldn't get his
cardiovascular health under control
because he wouldn't stop eating. So, if
you don't want to stop eating, you don't
want to stop doing eating the sugar,
then the GLP ones will help you. But the
problem is they're a drug and a they
only help you temporarily. When you get
off the GLP1 drugs, you're going to
balloon back up again and your blood
pressure is going to go up and you're
still going to have the same negative
cardiovascular markers that you had
before.
But even worse, you now have to deal
with toxicity and you have to deal with
side effects. So, I wanted AJ to see
this article because it reminded me how
the drug companies mislead us into
believing that their wares are
miraculous when in reality what they are
is band-aids that are that that are
appeal imitations of lifestyle choices
that we could be making that would have
real long-term benefits, real non-toxic
benefits, real longevity benefits. when
you see a GLP-1 RA GLP-1 agonist drug uh
improves a marker say in dermatitis what
you don't see is the side effects and
toxicities and the short longevity and
the nutritional deficiencies are going
to be associated secondary to taking the
GLP but they don't tell you that. So, I
wanted AJ to see that simply to to point
out the fact that it's not the GLP1
that's the miracle. It's the uh uh blood
sugar stabilization that is the miracle.
And you don't need a GLP-1 to do it.
Now, if you really want to have an
exogenous substance to to stabilize your
blood sugar, we got the GLP1 uh the GLP1
support kit, and we could talk about
that. Now, the GLP1 support kit is not
like a drug. It's a support kit. It
supports your own GLP-1. Real quickly,
GLP-1, so people know what GLP1s do,
they improve insulin sensitivity is how
they work. When you improve insulin
sensitivity, every single marker of um
of disease improves and on top of all
that, you don't eat as much. You're
satisfied quicker. So, you lose weight.
So, the GLP1s are not the miracle. It's
the stabilization of blood sugar that's
the miracle. And you don't need a GLP-1
drug to do it. Our GLP-1 system or or
GLP-1 kit, if you will. Um, there's
three there's you want to talk about
that real quick? That's not a that
doesn't work.
>> That's not a GLP-1 drug. That's a
support system. That's actually called
support system. A GLP-1 support system.
Um,
GLP-1 first of all suppresses your
appetite. It slows down the release of
food from the stomach so you're
satisfied longer. It improves blood
sugar control. Um, and it has a um
control improves what they call satiety,
satisfaction at the neurochemical level.
The longevities activate, elevate,
regulate three products. They don't work
that way. They support your own GLP1. So
you got the fiber product. That's the
first um I think they call that uh is
that the regulate? I think they call
that regulate. Is that right?
>> Yeah, I think that's regulate.
>> Okay, that it's that's the regulate. Um
and that is a um prebiotic fiber uh
prebiotic that helps feed good bacteria.
And this should never be lost on
anybody. Probably it's not on people on
this call, but there's a very important
relationship between the digestive
system and the blood sugar system via
the intestine and the liver. And that's
why the first point leads to the second
point on the triangle of disease. So the
GLP uh the YGY regulate, the first of
the GLP-1 um products feeds, it's
prebiotic. Prebiotic means it feeds your
gut bacteria. Your gut bacteria then in
turn generate what's called short chain
fatty acids, butyric acid or butyrate,
which we talked about largely uh
stabilize blood sugar and then it makes
you more satisfied. It's the soil that
allows the GLP-1 system to work. You got
psyllium in there, um, inulin, acacia,
and resistant starch. There's also, um,
FOS in there, fructosaccharides.
Um, you might want to consider using
your ultimate enzymes with it. And also,
of course, plant derived minerals go
with everything. Then the second product
in the in the system is um, your
activate, and that's the booster. that's
made with three uh three supplements.
Arginine, rveratrol, and then tart
cherry. Arginine is probably the most
important amino acid or at least one of
I would say it's the most, but at least
one of the most important amino acids
for helping with blood sugar. It
supports nitric oxide, supports blood
flow. It's got a lot of benefits.
Rveratrol these days, everybody knows
about rveratrol.
Um but rveratrol is claim to fame in
terms of blood sugar controls. that
improves your insulin sensitivity and
then you get the anti-inflammatory
support of the of the uh tart cherry. So
that's your GLP-1 booster that supports
your own GLP-1. And then uh the last
product is your sport shot, your uh
GLP1, I'm sorry, your um uh longevity uh
what's it called? Elevate GLP1 sport
shot support shot. And that will
directly stimulate satiety hormones. So
basically your all of the three pro all
the three products taken together will
help your own GLP1.
GLP1 by the way is mostly a intestinal
hormone and that's why there's all this
microbiome support uh in the GLP-1
support system kit. The point being you
don't need a GLP-1 drug. You want to
support your own GLP1. And the problem
with GLP-1 drugs is like all drugs, they
work quickly, but there's a price to be
paid later. you don't want to if you
don't want to work uh if if you don't
want to have to pay the price later in
terms of nutritional deficiency or a
rebound, go with your GLP-1 support kit,
watch your uh watch the your intake of
refined carbohydrates and sugars,
exercise, drink more water, rest, all
the things that we have to do to to not
just stabilize your blood sugar, improve
cardiovascular and improve
cardiovascular health, but for your
longevity as well. But I want everybody
to see that these you're when you read
these studies on how wonderful GLP1
drugs are, don't think, oh, the GLP-1
drug is so wonderful, think stabilizing
my blood sugar, working on the second
point of the triangle of disease. That's
where all the wonderfulness comes from.
And by the way, um, GLP-1 drugs sit in
the body uh, uh, for days. GLP-1, real
GLP-1 in the body is a is is cleared out
in minutes. So when you take a GLP-1
drug, you're throwing off your body's
biochemistry for days. And this is
another problem with drugs is the body
has to clear these drugs out like
poisons.
Is that I I don't know how that alone
should freak everybody. You got to clear
these drugs out as if they're poisons.
That's not true about a the GLP1 support
system from longevity or your your own
natural glucagon like peptide GLP that
you make. Well, and when you're
supporting the body's natural functions,
you're not going to have the negative
side effects that are being reported.
>> You're going to have no side effects,
including Yeah. intestinal side effects,
bleeding, retinal bleeding, and I mean,
just
>> muscle loss,
>> muscle loss, zic face as they say, or
zic butt as they say. Um, yeah. Because
when you artificially
manipulate your appetite, you're going
to end up dealing with nutritional
deficiencies. And by the way, if you are
on a GLP-1 and anybody who's a
distributor working with patients or
clients on a GLP-1 receptor agonist, RA,
it becomes extra important that you do
your nutritional supplements. Extra
important that you do your healthy start
pack because number one, like you say,
you're going to be depriving your body
of nutrients because you're not eating
or you're eating less than you need to
eat. And then secondly, you have to deal
with the detoxification. So, as I've
always said, and we're going to talk
about it this in a minute with the gal
who wrote the letter, nutrients help
your drugs work better with some
exceptions where there's maybe some
interactions, some some cancel some um
some um interactions where one then one
cancels the other out, but that's that's
rare. For the most part, you don't have
to worry about this. You don't have to
worry about interactions because your
nutrients will help your drugs work
better. Now, you do have to tell your
doctor because if you're on a blood
thinner, for example, your nutrients may
make your blood thinner work better and
you can drop, you know, you'll be able
to reduce your dose in your blood
thinner, which is a good thing. But for
the most part, nutrients are going to
improve your body's ability to handle
prescription medication
>> where we can't tell somebody to stop
taking something.
>> No, you know, we should never
>> look at
>> you never want to tell somebody that
that's not our that's not that's not I
would never tell him. But, you know,
that's another point.
The doctor, as misguided as we may think
he is or she is, they're doing they're
trying to help you. They're doing their
best. There's no doctor that's trying to
hurt you. They're trying to help you.
They may be doing it in a misguided way,
and that's our opinion, but you don't
want to regard your physician as an
enemy, but that doesn't mean you have to
listen to everything they say. The
problem is is we don't feel comfortable
with our knowledge. So we feel like
disempowered when we go into an
interaction with uh with a physician
where we don't feel like we can make any
we h have the right to make an
assessment or right to make have an
opinion. Well, not only do you have a
right to make an opinion because it's
your body, but we should be well-versed
in how our medication's working or how
our how our particular biochemical
pathology is showing up. Because if you
don't know how your medication's working
or you don't know how your pathies work
is working out, you're going to become a
victim of whatever some authority figure
tells you. And we know and I get the
letters from folks who have had their
organs removed and they've got nothing
left practically their female
reproductive system or of their thyroid
or their or of their uh digestive their
digestive tract, their intestine, their
pancreas, their stomach even. It's just
heartbreaking what happens because we
don't understand our bodies and we trust
other people to handle it. That's why I
go to great pains and great lengths to
explain everything because I don't want
anybody just trusting me either. I want
you to understand it. I don't want to be
telling anybody what to do. I want
everybody to understand their own bodies
and how the medications are working visa
v their bodies themselves. Yes. Go
ahead. I'm sorry. Well, and I appreciate
the fact that that that is your approach
to it because that empowers us with more
information to say, yes, okay, does this
even make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Why did I poison my body when there's
another option
>> to to explore or act on?
>> And and also um
what I talk about and that's why I
always say I want to talk to doctors. I
love talking to physicians. What I
talking about is unfalsifiable.
It's not There's no way you could
disagree. These aren't assertions and I
didn't read it in a study somewhere.
This is just how everything's put
together. This is plumbing. It's just
the how the the system and the parts of
the system interact with each other. I'm
not making any assertions and I didn't
read anything in a study. It's just how
everything works together. And that's
why it's very important to me that I
talk to medical professionals and
especially talk to medical professionals
in front of people so they can hear and
they can hear the medical professional
saying, "Well, I can't argue with that,
Ben." Because they can't,
>> right?
>> They can't is there's nothing here
that's assertion or there's nothing here
that's not uh that that is falsifiable
at all. This is all just logical,
coherent engineering. And that's really
the we're talking about here. It's not
health, it's engineering. How everything
is put together in from an engineering
standpoint. That being said, why don't
we just Did that Did that explain the
GLP1 article? Anything else you want to
talk about here with the GLP1?
>> No, I think that's fantastic.
>> I just sent AJ I'm I'm not going to talk
about this, but I just sent him an
article that I just saw this morning or
this afternoon on fecal transplants. I
know it's a disgusting topic. Sorry to
say it, but uh and Parkinson's
how early Parkinson's symptoms are
dramatically improved by fecal
transplants. Well, what does that mean?
The gut and the and Parkinson's disease
are are intimately connected. It's not
people want to think your doctors will
tell you it's your brain. It's not your
brain. It's your digestive system. It
shows up in the brain, but that's not
where you can work. And I've known this
for decades since pharmacy school. And
you're going to see more and more about
this. I'm telling you that triangle
disease you guys you're going to in 20
years you're going to see everybody
talking about because those are the two
fundamental points and then if you want
to throw in the third point of course
the adrenal thyroid complex but that
bottom of the triangle is the key to
everything. It simplifies everything and
take that to your doctor and see what he
says. There's no way that they can deny
that. And you can learn more about the
triangle of disease by going to the
website triangleof disease all
oneword.com.
AJ I see your hand up. AJ did a great
job putting that together.
>> Yes, AJ does. And AJ, why don't you give
your a plug for your uh
>> talk tomorrow?
>> No, he did. AJ does a what did you call
it? Had some some funny name there. AJ,
what did you call your
>> Oh, it's private. Okay, never mind.
Sorry.
Yeah,
>> that means I don't know about it. That's
what he's trying to say.
>> You you you're usually there every
Saturday.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Go ahead, AJ. What's your
question?
>> So, um, Pharmacist Ben, there's a couple
of things. Um,
but you explained, you know, everything
masterfully as usual. Um,
I guess you know what I just what I took
away from what you said however is that
if you have no self-discipline
use the medical model if you can
>> and I don't like discipline discipline
sounds too scary you know but it's
choice you could say discipline if you
want but it's choice you know the
medical model is there as a convenience
for us in the sense that you can hack
into your bio biochemistry with a with a
beta blocker. Just to give you an
example, but if you have high blood
pressure, we talked about why you have
high blood pressure. The blood becomes
sticky and sludgy and organs don't get
fed. So, you can mechanically or or
biochemically hack into your blood
pressure uh your your hypertension by
forcing the vessels to open up and drop
the pressure, but that defeats what the
body's trying to do. You know, what we
call disease and pathology and
biochemical breakdown is really the body
adapting or trying to adapt to a a bad
situation. So, if you want to hack into
it, yeah, there's plenty of drugs
that'll do that, but there's always
going to be a cost. You know, if you
want to if you want to hack into it,
yeah, there's plenty of drugs you could
do that. You go to the doctor, your
insurance company will pay for it. If
you live in Europe or you live in
Canada, it's probably going to be free,
but there's going to be a price to be
paid for it. I don't know about I don't
know if I like self-discipline so much
but you know you could say it that way.
It's really a choice is what it is.
>> But I mean you know but
>> people don't know they have let me just
say this real quick. I'm sorry to
interrupt you. People don't know they
have choice.
You understand? They think and present
company excluded. Everybody in this call
knows they have a choice but the vast
majority of people don't know they have
an option. We're providing options,
gentle, non-toxic, compatible options
that don't require the body to have to
work to clean itself out. That's what
we're doing. This is these are choices
and options for people that want them.
Most people don't know they have choices
and options. Do you get that?
>> And then and when I talked in Florida to
these older folks, I guarantee you
they're all Senator Sip was saying
they're on medication. They don't know
there's options. And that's what we're
doing. Just letting people know their
options is going to help a certain
amount of people. Not everybody, but it
will help a certain amount of people,
>> right? Because there going to be some
people who will not fast for 24 hours to
to see how their symptoms improve. There
there will be a number of people who
will not change their diet. Uh will not
keep a food diary. Uh the simple things
that they can do to empower themselves.
>> Um
>> more more power to them. Jesus loves
everybody. they're fine,
you know, if that's what they want to
do. For people who don't want to do
that, who smell a rat, who feel more
comfortable not being on prescription
drugs, who want to increase their
longevity because there's no drugs that
are going to improve your longevity,
this is an option for them. So, I don't
want to I don't want to belabor this too
much because we got questions and we're
going to run out of time here. If we
could just unless you have unless you
have some questions,
>> I have a I have a caller question. Um
Ernie is 93, 180 pounds.
>> Wow. He w he he was 5'6, now he's 5'2.
>> Okay.
>> Uh his diagnosis was acute pancreatitis.
>> February 2024. Aphib and a stroke four
years ago. What kind of advice would you
give Ernie?
>> All right. Hang on. Ahib and a stroke
four years ago.
>> That's what That's what I was sent. Yes.
>> Okay. So, he had a and a stroke. And
what was the what's
>> acute pancreatitis?
>> But no, but how did the stroke like
what's he left with was the stroke? What
what did it affect?
>> I don't have that information.
>> So depending on what part of the body
was affected because he may have had his
digestive system. It might be the he
might had a digestive um there must
might have been digestive ramifications.
I don't know. So could be a little bit
little bit tricky. But the pancreas is
your uh enzyme factory. I call the
pancreas Mr. Cellophane. Did you ever
see that movie Chicago? Mr. Cellophane.
You remember Mr. Cellophane in Chicago?
>> I did not see Chicago.
>> Mr. Zella thing was transparent. Nobody
could see him. He was like ignored. They
called him Mr. There's a big song about
it, etc. The idea being we don't notice
it. We didn't notice him. That's what I
call the pancreas. We don't notice the
pancreas. We don't think about the
pancreas until something happens because
we have pancreatitis. You know, you're
going to you have something happen.
Pancreas, there's a reason why
pancreatic cancer is the most has a
reputation for being the most deadly of
all cancers. The pancreas is an enzyme
factory. It makes enzymes
and uh as far as its digestive role
digestive function is when you eat a
food and it goes into your into your
intestine from your stomach the pancreas
shoots a bunch of juices along with the
gallbladder and and and and bile
pancreatic juices neutralize stomach
acid. So there plays a major major role
in the digestive process. It also plays
a major role in blood sugar. So you
could see you got the two points of
triangle of the triangle disease right
there in one gland in the pancreas. So
it's a food problem and it's a sugar
problem. That's your pancreas. Food and
sugar. So what do you do? Well, you got
to change the way you eat first of all.
There's certain nutrients that you can
take that will help as well. So sodium
bicarbonate, which is made in the
pancreas, can also help if you use
sodium baking soda or uh baking soda. Um
teaspoon of baking soda every day or
with your meals. baking soda, not with
your meals, after your meals because
it'll neutralize your stomach acid.
Maybe two hours after your meals, do a
little bit of baking soda or you can do
baking soda just on a daily basis to
support the pancreas. Um, also your
ultimate enzymes will support the
pancreas and anything you can do for
blood sugar will support the pancreas
such as um the healthy blood sugar path.
>> So, you want to treat you want to treat
pancreatic acute pancreatitis as
digestive issue and blood sugar issue.
Now, if you're an alcoholic, that will
also stress the pancreas. And if you
have gallstones, that will also put a
burden on the pancreas. Um, so between
uh foods, sugar, gallstones, or if
you're an alcoholic, which I assume that
if he's 93, he's not an alcoholic. Um,
those are the places where you want to
work on the pancreas. The ultimate
enzymes and the healthy blood sugar pack
are the two are the the u two main uh
young protocols that I would use. But
also, I would be working on digestive
health as well.
first point of trunkal disease.
>> Sound like the first time I've ever
heard uh uh in this community us talk
about reducing the effects of stomach
acid.
>> I didn't say reducing. Did I say
reducing the sto?
>> Well, you said the sodium bicarbonate.
>> No, I said if you use sodium bicarbonate
with your meals, you'll neutralize
stomach acid and that's not a good
thing, which is why you want to take
sodium bicarbonate a couple hours after
your meals.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. Yeah. You don't want to decrease
stomach acid. That's true.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much for
that. Um,
so Ernie, you're going strong. Let's
keep you going.
>> Yeah. 93 is amazing. 93 is amazing.
>> That's awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome. Um, well, pharmacist Ben, I
sent you an email and we have Miriam on
with us right now. Miriam,
go ahead and unmute and please present
your question. Let's let's help your
mama. Another one of those individuals
who is live living a long life and let's
keep her going.
>> Thank you, Becca. Yes, my mom is also 92
years old.
>> Nice. My mom, too.
>> Oh, wonderful. I think your mom is
probably healthier than mine. She had a
hemorrhagic stroke a few years ago, so
she can't take blood thinners, but she's
on a very low dose of aspirin to prevent
blood clots. Apparently, it did not work
though because she had a blood clot
stroke anyway last month. So, she is my
in my sister's care. So, I recommended
to my sister that she give my mom
fuccoidin because it's an
anti-coagulant. My sister Googled it and
read that Google says do not givein to
someone who is taking aspirin, which of
course my mom is taking. So, is Google
just correctly assuming that you don't
want to make the blood thinner if you
are already thinner?
>> Is not going to make the blood thinner?
No nutritional supplements will make the
blood thinner. They will
they will adjust the blood if it's too
thick, but they're not going to make the
blood thinner. Drugs make the blood
thinner. The medical model, Google, and
unfortunately some people conflate
nutritional supplementation with drugs.
And we are partially responsible, I have
to say, because we say things like
fuccoidin thins the blood. Essential
fatty acid thin the blood. Um, you know,
um, vitamin E thins the blood. They
don't thin the blood. They support
fluidity of the blood. They're not going
to thin it. A drug will thin the blood.
A drug, I'm going to give my metaphor
again, which, you know, it's I like
telling the story because it's really
illustrative, but I don't want anybody
to get sick of it, but it's really
important. Drugs hit the rock.
Nutrients ask the rock. You You
understand what I'm saying from the
Bible?
>> Yes, I do.
>> Doctors don't make that distinction.
The media doesn't make that distinction.
Unfortunately, some people don't make
that distinction. Nutrients do not hit
the rock. They don't thin the blood.
Google's confused because Google works
for the medical model and the medical
model owns Google.
That's what I thought. Excellent.
>> Dupointin does not thin the blood like a
blood thinner. It supports blood
fluidity. That's a different thing than
thinning the blood.
>> Wonderful. Thank you.
>> Good. There you go. Now, there's also
other nutrient there's other ways that
she should be thinning the blood and and
I don't want to say thin the blood
supporting blood fluidity.
>> Oxygen. Making sure she's breathing
correctly. Chances are she's not. Oxygen
has a fluid fluid fluidizing fluidity
supporting effect. Think that's the
right way to say it. Water has a
fluidity supporting effect. Essential
fats have a fluidity supporting effect.
Digestive enzymes have a fluidity
supporting effect. That's taken on an
empty stomach. Uh vitamin E has a
fluidity supporting effect. Plantder
derived minerals have a fluidity
supporting effect. These are all going
to support blood fluidity. They're not
going to thin the blood though. they're
going to have a fluidity supporting
effect. Real quickly, the blood clotting
um process is regulated by what's called
a cascade.
That means
reaction one causes reaction two causes
reaction three causes reaction four
causes reaction five 6 7 8 9 10 11 12.
Just like that Rub Goldberg machine we
talked about or mouse trap. You know,
you know what I'm talking about, Miriam?
>> Yes. Yes. Just like mouse trap, just
like Rub Goldberg machine, and it's
extremely
extremely regulated. Probably the most
regulated process in all of biology is
blood thinning and blood clotting. Why
do you suppose that would be? Because
it's so important. But what have we done
over the last 150 years? We figured out
a way to keep the blood clotting all the
time, or at least sludgy and sticky,
through foods.
So, we're all dealing with this problem.
All disease is cell disease, but all
cell disease is preceded by dirty blood.
The reason the digestive system and the
blood sugar system are so important in
the first two points on the triangle of
disease is because that's how the blood
becomes yucky, sticky, sludgy, viscous,
clotted. So, your mother would be way
better off in addition to the
supplements we just talked about and the
oxygen and the water to control her
blood sugar and work on her digestive
system, but she's not going to get that
information from her doctor. And at 92
years old, she may not want to do it.
So, I would be, and this is not just for
your for your mom, but anybody who's
listening, I'd be working on digestive
health, blood sugar health, using all
the things we just talked about to help
naturally fluidize the blood if I was
dealing with any kind of blood clotting
or blood blood thinning situation.
>> Thank you so much, Ben. I do have a
second question.
>> Does that all that make sense, though?
>> Yes, it's perfect. A perfect answer. I
think it will reassure my sister very
much. Plus, your mom's probably
sedentary, I would imagine. No.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, that's going to have it that's going
to sludge um lead to more sludgess.
Things aren't moving. They're not
circulating appropriately. So, even
something like even something like um
you ever see those little things where
you can they're not bicycles, but they
look like a bicycle where you just pedal
with your feet. I s like that would make
a huge difference for her.
>> Excellent. I will let her know. Okay. My
my second question is you just said that
some nutrients cancel out the effects of
medic of medication. So I wanted to know
which drugs if any
>> does fucoidin cancel out because
>> is not going to cancel out any drugs.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> However, fucoidant
>> and and keep in mind with the fucoid z
you're getting a very little small
you're not getting a lot of algae in
there. Theoretically though fiber can
lock up if you take a lot of fiber with
your medication like at the same time
the the fiber can can chilate or can
attach to the drugs and you may not get
this you know you may not get the same
uh the drugs may lose some potency but
that fucoin you're not going to have
that problem.
>> Excellent. Thank you so much.
>> And by the way fucoin is great for
everybody not just for sick people not
just for people who need medication.
Everybody benefits from fucoidin. It's
an incredibly non-toxic leotropic as we
say multifunctional um nut uh
nutritional supplement or dietary
supplement.
>> Great. Well, actually, can I throw in
another question? My dad has diabetes.
So, how would I if he started fucoidin,
would he just have to keep track with
his doctor about when to decrease that?
>> No. Fukcoin's like seaweed. Does he tell
you every time your dad eats sushi, does
he tell your doctor?
>> No.
>> I mean, it's just it's just basically
seaweed. And it's interesting because
seaweed and grass are two of the most
powerful medicinal substances on the
planet. As it turns out, grass is harder
for us to to process because the
nutrients are locked up in the grass.
But seaweed is like sear grass
essentially seaweed and the nutrients
have been released by the water. So
seaweed is powerful powerful powerful
nutrition with every single nutrient of
the n mighty nine essential nutrients
contained therein plus some
non-essential nutrients like the
polysaccharides like fucoidin. Do you
guys get the fucoidin is algae is brown
algae. It's the active one of the active
ingredients in brown algae.
>> Yes. So how would you recommend somebody
um weaning off their medicine if they
becomes more and more healthy?
>> You wean off your medicine. You take
less every day. You take half a dose,
half a, you know, then day one take half
a dose or day two take half a dose and
day three take a quarter dose, day four
take a quarter dose, day five take a
16th of a dose. Just reduce the dose,
but do it with your physician.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay, great. Excellent.
Thank you.
>> Okay. Thank you, Miriam.
>> Thank you, Miriam. And let's go right
over to AJ. And then I have a question
coming in from email.
>> Yes.
>> Hey, for this is Ben. Uh, we should do
we should do Ben bites during the day
because you're on fire.
>> During the day?
>> Yeah.
>> What? More than more than at night.
>> Yeah, I catch you at night. You know,
like
>> I'm a little down.
>> I get up at 4 in the morning, man.
>> I'm just joking. And people loved your
performance on uh Coast to Coast, by the
way. They
>> Oh, did they?
>> Yes, they did.
>> All right, cool.
>> Um, okay. So, first
>> performance. What performance? What
>> performance? Yeah. How you were active.
before
>> how you were how you were doctoring the
show.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, um, someone's got a question.
Uh, Sheay Brookside can't get rid of my
high cholesterol according to my doctor,
but I won't let her put me on statin.
What is the product he is advertising in
this promo? And I'm guessing
>> healthy blood sugar, healthy blood sugar
pack, and the ultimate nasin. And then
smart
>> fucoid Z fucoid I'm sorry fucoid Z also
has a anti- lipidmic or anti- blood fat
blood cholesterol effect
>> and then asking if smart FX will assist
in the cholesterol issue.
>> Smart FX I have to say I'm not familiar
with that off the top of my head. Are
you
>> smart effects or some EFAs?
>> EFAs are awesome for all blood issues.
Smart FX is just essential fatty acids.
>> Becca, those are EPA and DHA, right?
>> What is it? What is I don't remember. I
don't think I ever heard.
>> I think they're EPA and DHA.
>> EPA and DHA are specific for the brain.
They're not necessarily They're not
going to hurt the blood. Um, and they
probably have some some benefits, but
they're not specifically going to lower
blood cholesterol. Essential fatty acids
might though. your ultimate EFAs and
ultimate EFA plus
>> cholesterol. I I know we say this all
the time, but it's just worth repeating.
Do we have new people on the call?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Always.
>> Okay. Okay. Good. So, um cholesterol
is a building substance. It's not the
enemy. It's a building substance. It's
an anabolic substance. If you're coming
from surgery, your cholesterol will go
up. Young people have higher
cholesterol, blood cholesterol. um uh
athletes, people are lifting weights,
etc., etc.
because it helps you build. You can't
make cells without cholesterol.
The muscles depend on cholesterol. Your
steroid hormones depend on cholesterol.
Your bile depends on cholesterol.
Vitamin D depends on cholesterol. It's
an absolute
biochemical
it's it's the height of biochemical
ignorance to shut down cholesterol
production artificially. It's just epic.
And in a hundred years, they were going
to look back at us and think we were the
dumbest culture in the history of
mankind. That we pharmacologically shut
down the poison really literally
poisoned the um the cells that make
cholesterol, the cholesterol,
the cholesterol pathway, if you will.
Why does cholesterol go up then? Well,
first of all, before we say why it goes
up, what are they thinking? What what's
the logic? Why would they want to lower
cholesterol? What's the health logic to
lowering cholesterol? Do you know what?
What are they thinking? L not whe
they're right or wrong.
>> Heart disease. Heart disease.
>> Why heart disease? Why heart disease?
>> Well, they're thinking that cholesterol
is is blocking a pathway.
>> Correct. No, not a pathway. Blocking the
blood vessel, blocking the movement of
blood.
>> Okay.
>> There's cholesterol plaques
that deposit in the arteries.
These cholesterol plaques cause
blockages, right? And then the heart
doesn't get oxygenating. Okay? So the
thinking is well let's shut down
cholesterol production so we stop the
blockages. But then the you have to say
why is the cholesterol causing the
blockages? What's going on? Why are
there cholesterol blockages? Not why is
the cholesterol being made but why are
there cholesterol blockages? We'll talk
about why the cholesterol is being made
in a second but why are there blockages?
Well, let's examine this. And this is
how you have to do it. Remember doctor
medicine's not a science. Medicine's not
a science. Medicine doesn't work like
that. Medicine is simply shutting down
symptoms.
It doesn't work on the biochemical
mechanisms that cause the symptoms. It
just artificially shuts them down. So
why where are the cholesterol blockages?
Are they in the what? In what part of
the circulatory system are they in the
veins?
>> No, they're in the arteries.
That's a major clue right there. Are
they in the capillaries? No, they're in
the arteries.
and especially in the big arteries close
to the heart. That's where you have the
block main blockages. So there's a clue
there and this is how you have why you
have to understand biochemistry and
biology and and physiology to really
figure this thing out. So you got
blockages in the arteries but not in the
veins. So what does that mean? That
means there's something different about
the arteries than the veins is causing
the blockages. So what's the difference?
Well, the arteries are more susceptible
to pressure issues because they're
closer to the heart, right? You have a
circle. The heart's in the middle. This
is very basic. The high pressure is in
the front. There's not high pressure in
the back end. The high pressure is in
the front end.
So, why would there be cholesterol uh
deposits where there's high pressure?
Because where there's high pressure, you
have more damage.
If you have a weakened vascular system,
you're going to have more damage in the
front end than in the back end because
the front end is subject to more forces.
Are you with me?
>> Yes.
>> Make sense?
>> So, right away we can see cholesterol
deposits are related to pressure.
They're related to weakness of the
vascule. So, what you want to work on is
the vascule system, the blood system,
not the cholesterol.
You want to work on the arteries.
How do you work on the arteries? Well,
first of all, the arteries are made of
connective tissue. So, you work on your
connective tissue, healthy bone and
joint pack. Secondly, the arteries are
very, very, very susceptible to
glycation issues,
sugaring,
glycation, so you work on your blood
sugar.
And third of all,
the arteries are going to be damaged by
dirty blood. So you work on the
digestive system.
It all boils down to the triangle. And
then the compound matters. Cholesterol
levels are intimately connected to
insulin. Elevated insulin, elevated
cholesterol.
>> Elevated blood sugar, elevated insulin,
elevated cholesterol. So another reason
to work on the second point of the
triangle of disease. There's nowhere in
health in in sickness
that you cannot improve by working on
the triangle of disease. And even just
the first two points, forget the
triangle. The digestive system and the
blood sugar system. That's it.
Everything. Everything. So if you don't
want to be on a statin drug, lower your
blood sugar or get on the healthy blood
sugar pack or not or and get on the
healthy blood sugar pack and all the
other strategies. Drinking more drinking
more water alone will dilute your blood
sugar. Exercise will dilute your blood
sugar
and of course eating less sugar will
dilute your blood sugar or will reduce
your blood sugar. And uh yeah, and you
always say drink a tall glass of water
when you first wake up in the morning.
>> First thing in the morning if you're
diabetic and you're testing your blood,
test your blood every morning and drink
a 32 ounce glass of good clean water and
watch your blood sugar concentration
because blood sugar means blood sugar
concentration.
That's the mean in other words the
amount of sugar per unit of blood.
That's what blood sugar concentration
is. When you dilute the blood, the blood
sugar just mathematically will drop.
Blood sugar concentration will drop.
>> Someone uh emailed in what's the
relationship between kidneys and
oxalates.
>> All right, so oxalates are a waste
product. There are oxalates in food and
sometimes you'll hear people talking
about avoiding high oxalate foods and
that's maybe not a bad thing, but there
turns out that some of the foods that
have oxalate, spinach, which is very
high oxalate, are good foods for you. So
bodily if you have high oxalates you've
got some metabolic issues some
biochemical issues because oxalates are
waste product and it's no accident that
people who are eating a lot of sugar
particularly fructose have high
oxalates. Oxalates are crystals and they
can saturate the blood.
Like remember we talked about how if you
have a water and you put salt in the
water, the salt goes in, another
teaspoon of salt goes in, third
teaspoon, fourth teaspoon, eventually it
precipitates,
>> saturates,
>> it saturates, right? So oxalates will
saturate the blood when it's or will
contribute to blood saturation when the
blood is already sticky and sludgy and
stuff is accumulating in the blood.
Don't blame the oxalates. Blame the
blood and blame the metabolism. But once
you have oxalates going, if you have
high oxalates, that can definitely cause
kidney problems, oxalate stones and
such. And that is a not pleasant
experience.
I would I would first of all more water.
That's one thing you could do to dilute
the blood um from the oxalates and
improve kidney function. Um and then
also con consider a metabolic issue,
i.e. first two points in the triangle of
disease.
There's no way to get around it, you
guys. There's no way to get around the
first two points in the triangle of
disease. It ain't if if you want to
recover in a non-toxic way.
>> Go ahead,
>> AJ.
>> Yeah. So, would you think that the um
the the Youngevity GLP program
>> be helpful for someone
>> who's
>> diabetic,
>> dealing thinking about oxalates, wanting
to clean the blood sugar? it would it's
not going to hurt but nobody should
think that the GLP1 support system
replaces the healthy start pack
>> right no
>> the healthy start pack is the basic and
if you don't want by the way if you
don't want you know if you're
distributor out there and somebody is
bulking at the healthy start pack
they're not sure and they don't want the
beyond tanky tangerine just do the
planter minerals that will make a
difference and I think that's like $39
how much is the plant the mineral totty
uh
I think it's like it's very inexpensive.
>> Plant derived minerals or ultimate
classic liquid
>> um planter derived minerals just
>> 24
>> $24
and that will make a difference. The
planter minerals will clean the blood.
It's one of the one of the hidden
benefits of plantery minerals is they
clean the blood. They improve blood
fluidity on their own.
>> And I just so but if you you have more
interest in knowing about this stuff,
you can go to dailywithdocam.com. You
can go to triangleofold disease.com. You
can go to rootnoutfruit.com and you can
go to powergl.com.
Or you can look at the description and
you'll see all the other wonderful
websites that Becca Dukes
made sure we had.
>> Well, AJ, thank you so much as you've
been very instrumental in that as well.
>> Pharmacist Ben, one more question and
couple comments. So Bruce out on Rumble
says, "We love Ben."
>> Oh, thank you,
>> Olga. um out on YouTube says, "Beutrate
fuels GLP1
are guts builtin weight management
system."
>> Say that. Say it one more time.
Butyrate.
>> Butyrate.
>> But yeah, butyrate is unreal stuff. The
third um the fiber product. Is that the
third one or the first one?
>> The first one. Regulate.
>> The first one. Yeah, the regulate.
Right. Regulate will support butyrate
production. Exactly. I think that's what
Bruce is talking about.
>> Wonderful. Or Olga. Yeah,
>> Olga.
>> Um, okay. Last question. Pharmacist Ben.
This one is coming in from Gary, uh, one
of our critical health news subscribers.
He says,
um, the people treating me want to give
me chemotherapy for a sty on the inside
of my lower right eyelid. I have
>> chemotherapy.
>> Wait, wait. Chemotherapy like what?
Yeah, just
>> okay.
>> Just listen. I have suffered with this
sty since last summer. It is large, red,
swollen, and painful. Treatments have
included warm compresses, antibiotic
savves, two steroid injections directly
into the eyelid. I've been treating my
general treated by my general practice
physician, an optometrist, and a PA
specializing in sty. Nothing has worked.
The sty is still there. And now I'm
being told that experimental
chemotherapy is the only treatment left.
Treatment would involve eyelid
injections of C or 5FU
five. What is that?
>> Five
fluoroicil.
>> Um the number of injections has not been
determined. It's an experiment.
>> What else does this person is this
person on the call?
>> He is not on the call. So the question
to ask for for if we're helping the
person and and we can help them call
what else do do they have?
>> A sty is a
I'm not convinced if they're giving
chemotherapy it might not be a sty
because a sty is bacteria.
>> So it might not be a stye. They may be
calling it a sty or he may be calling it
a sty but a sty is like a pimple. It's a
pusfilled bump on your eyelid.
>> Right? So, if they're giving them
chemotherapy and if it's been there for
a long time, it might not be a sty. It
could be if it's not bacteria, it could
be a blocked gland, like an oil gland
that's blocked. Um, it could be uh
that's basically it. Um, but it could be
something like a cyst. It might not be
bacteria. It might not be a pus. It
could be just cells that are dividing
very rapidly. You know, it's hard to
imagine this, but you got to kind of
force yourself to.
>> If you take just your skin and and the
eyelid is part of the skin system,
obviously, but if you take your skin,
you've got openings in in the skin. What
are those called? Pores, right?
>> Pores.
>> The pores are in the top and then
there's a rabbit hole in the bottom.
>> The pores are the opening to the rabbit
hole. The rabbit hole is called a
follicle. This is in your eyelid, too.
It's hard to imagine this because it's
so thin, but these follicles are
microscopic. So they're in this even
though the eyelid is thin. And so what
happens is in this rabbit hole, the
rabbit hole is lined with cells like
every other part of the body. The rabbit
hole is actually skin, but it's
invaginated. It goes in. So it's part of
your skin. And the cells, just like on
the top of your skin, are dividing,
right? Well, in the follicle, they're
dividing. But if they divide out of
control,
that's where you start to get cysts.
Millia sometimes people will call them.
There's bacteria, they'll call it a zit
or a pimple, but this the initiating um
cause
is cells dividing rapidly out of
control. How cells divide is tightly
controlled. It's regulated. There's
steps
uh cells are born in the stem cell area
in the bottom of the skin. It's like a
nursery. Then they come out. They
they're they're um they morph from stem
cells. They're called skin cells at that
point or keratinocytes. That's the
technical name because they make keratin
which is a protein. And then they rise
to the top. This is why exfoliation is
so important. And normally if you're
healthy, the cells will flop off. And if
you're uh for those of you guys sitting
in a room, there's there's dead skin
cells flying all over the the room. 50%
or 60% of the average dust bunny under
your bed is skin cells that have been
flopping off from people's face or
bodies. As we age, that doesn't happen
as rapidly. Nothing happens as rapidly
as we age. And that's why exfoliation is
so. In any case, a sty or a boil, not a
sty, but a boil or not a cyst is the end
result of cells dividing too rapidly. A
sty typically will have bacteria in it.
But if they're giving chemotherapy for
this person, it's probably not
bacterial. It's probably more like a
cyst. In which case, it's a sign that
cells are dividing too rapidly. Cells
dividing too rapidly are caused by a few
different things. Number one,
nutritional deficiencies, particularly
in vitamin A, vitamin D, and fats. Now,
it could be that they're not absorbing.
And that's why I want to ask this person
about digestive health, if they have
gallbladder, um if they if they bloat or
feel uncomfortable after certain foods.
There's all kinds of questions I'd want
to ask also because insulin
makes things divide really rapidly.
There could be an insulin connection.
Hello.
First two points on the triangle of
disease.
>> And that's why that's why I want to talk
to the person. But chemotherapy just
represents desperation. What
chemotherapy do is going to do is going
to kill the cells and then they won't
divide rapidly. No problem. Of course,
now you're dealing with chemotherapy.
Now they are injecting it which is a
little bit better than taking it orally,
but 5FU is a really nasty substance. Um
and you know I would personally I would
be looking at what else is going on in
this person's life or in this person
with this person's health. That would be
the appropriate question. If they want
to supplement, it would be thing. It
would be fats, vitamin A, vitamin D,
ultimate EFAs, healthy star pack, of
course. Um,
see if there's anything else. That would
be the the most important thing that
comes to mind. But I would want to ask
this person because it doesn't sound
like it's a bacterial infection. And
that that's what a sty typically is.
>> Okay. I'll be reaching out to Gary
getting more information. And yeah,
that's what we do, folks, is we get down
to the root cause. We're not looking at
the fruit. We're looking at the root.
Just like the website root notfruit.com
>> and the pharmacist Ben, we're at the top
of the hour. I know you've got to get
out.
>> I do have to go. Thank you so much.
>> Co-hosts that would greatly appreciate
be appreciated. Have a happy Easter.
>> Happy Easter. And I'll see you on
Wednesday.
>> I'll see you on Wednesday.
>> Okay. You're going to When do you get
there? When do you get it in Florida?
>> Uh we start driving Tuesday through the
night. So thankful. There's more than
one driver.
>> Okay.
>> And um we'll be there Wednesday
afternoon.
>> Okay. I'll see you next week. Bye
everybody.
>> All right. Bye for now.
>> And thank you so much everybody for
joining us here on Daily with Doc and
Becca. And I am so thankful, full of
gratitude for the people that are on the
screen with me right now as they help
make my job so much easier even when
they mute me. But that's okay. I've been
there and done it myself. So, thank you
so much, Ruth Ellen, as my executive uh
production manager as she is helping to
put everything together into the video
with the graphics, pushing it out onto
all the different platforms. Thank you.
and Rod for being out on all the
platforms, keeping an eye on things,
bringing in questions. Thank you. And
replying to them, and Albert for letting
people in as he is our gatekeeper
way
down south in South Africa. Thank you so
much, Albert, for all that you do and
being up when you should be sleeping.
and Marilyn. Thank you so much, Marilyn.
And she is Miss Speedy Fingers doing
dictation into the chat, which is only
available if you are here live with us
by going to zoom.dwithdoc.com.
Now, this is a new link, folks. Okay?
It's going to ask you to sign in, have a
code, send to your email, and then the
next time you go to zoom.doc, daily with
doc. If you are approved to be into the
room, you'll be able to be let in, but
you do have to sign in with your Zoom
account. We want to make sure that
everybody who is here is here because
they really want to be here to learn,
not cause trouble. And last but
certainly not least, we have AJ who has
been very instrumental in helping us
with our marketing um uh with these
different websites and also getting the
word out through all the different
platforms. And thank you. Thank you to
you watching and listening because as
you are listening and absorbing
information and sharing with others, you
and I and everybody listening and doing
the sharing are helping make this world
a healthier place. These are actionable
items, folks. So, make sure that you get
back with the person that shared this
program with you. If there's no one to
thank, you can go to dailywithdoc.com.
You can look in if you're here watching
us later date or on a platform, look in
the description. Like AJ said, we've got
lots of different websites there to give
you more in-depth information about
things that are most concerning to you.
We want to make it easy. And on each of
those websites, there is a store there
so that you can get things in the mail
coming to you much quicker. If you'd
like to speak with somebody again, get
back with the person that shared this
program with you. If there is no one to
thank, we do have a call team at
855-9493377.
Again, 855-9493377.
That is our team of certified holistic
health coaches. If you'd rather use
email,
you can email questions
dailywithdoc.com
or you can even text message the
8559493377.
So again, thank you so much for joining
us. If you're watching on one of the
platforms, make sure you have
subscribed. Show us some love and show
somebody else some love by sharing this
information with them. Don't forget,
have a safe and fantastic
weekend and Monday.
Monday, are we having bin bites?
Think we got bin Bites on Monday, but
Daily with Doc the live presentations
will be on vacation Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday of next week.
But we may have a special little
surprise. So, you want to make sure that
you are
getting notifications of when we go
live. Ruth Ellen, I saw your hand go up.
>> Yes. I just want to wish everyone a
happy Easter. Enjoy
your family.
>> Happy Easter
and Good Friday to each and every one of
you.
>> Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
for post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and Soil Sciences,
Doctor of Veterary Medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
Doctor.